jetzt gibt es ermittlungen gegen drei
bahnmitarbeiter es geht um das tragische
zugunglück bei garmisch partenkirchen
dort fünf menschen gestorben jetzt ein
ermittlungsverfahren gegen drei personen
wegen des verdachts der fahrlässigen
tötung darüber sprechen wir mit unserem
reporter karl heim direkt dort vom
unglücksort geschaltet karl weiss genau
kannst du uns über diesen stand der
ermittlungen sagen
ja nach bild-informationen richtet sich
der tatverdacht hier gegen den
verantwortlichen
streckenverantwortlichen gegen den
lokführer und gegen den fahrdienstleiter
man muss das ganz kurz erklären richtet
sich auch gegen den lokführer und bei
den fahrdienstleiter weiß natürlich
aktiv an diesem geschehen beteiligt
waren das kann auch da wieder
eingestellt werden diese ermittlungen
man muss ja so verstehen wie im
straßenverkehr wenn wir angenommen wir
sind nun unter dem auto unterwegs und
dann fahren wir einen motorradfahrer
oder ein fußgänger an und auch wenn uns
dann vielleicht keine schuld trifft wird
man natürlich immer erst als
beschuldigter geführt um das dann auch
ganz klar zu ermitteln aber wohl der
fokus liegt voll auf diesen strecken
verantwortlichen denn wir wissen ja dass
ende juni hier
gleisarbeiten stattfinden sollen gleis
lage berichtigung die das so in bahnen
deutsch heißt im behördendeutsch das
heißt jede schiene hat ja da gibt es
gewisse maße wie breit müssen die sein
wie hoch dürfen die seien hier in diesem
gebiet und das sollte wohl korrigiert
werden und jetzt ist die frage die bahn
warum so spät die bahn hat es offenbar
bewusst gewusst dass da etwas nicht
stimmt es sollten gleisbauarbeiten
durchgeführt werden und ja wie man jetzt
sieht wohl offenbar zu spät und das
hätte wohl verhindert werden können
diese stimme zukunft mit diesen fünf
toten und das ist so der aktuelle stand
der ermittlungen vielen dank für die
aktuellen ermittlungen und ihr bleibt
natürlich dran und sobald es neuigkeiten
gibt kommen wir zu dir zurück